john hayes alors c'est un copain ils
arrivèrent cyril et il lui dieu
cyril de tintin 100 euros sur toi et
celui où ça ou ça c'est un coup c'est un
couple ils sont devant la télé et
regarde les numéros du loto était là sa
grille devant lui le 5 et 10 buts il dit
sur yon là je le sache et ça dès le 2 x
files de ses 32 h 1 il a tout et 5
numéros et les 2 étoiles ont gagné 27
millions alors oublions ça à l'autre il
fait des monde 2002 il sort il ou au
balcon il dit le coiffeur et les
charcutière 27 handbag on comprend pas
une baisse à descendre tous les deux
kataka de l'escalier traverse la rue et
à sang là il ya un bus
quels travaux il sa femme allait carpet
par terre le mail qui regarde sa femme
regarde ce qui est dit [ __ ] la journée
est bonne
gilles ouais j'en ai mes journées c'est
une mère juive qui veut qui veut faire
faire un costard son fils pour la bar
mitzvah super important et va chez le
tailleur du coin qui a d'ailleurs
vraiment je vais faire un truc super
pour mon fils donc je veux le le costard
nickel rien ne dépasse tous super vous
êtes vous inquiété pas pas de problème
et prend les mesures tac je désire
impeccable c'est dans une semaine le
costard il est fait y'a pas de problème
aucun souci une semaine plus tard ils
reviennent avec le fiston bien sûr elle
arrive alors monsieur voilà vue mais le
costard impeccable super sur-mesure tout
rires des passes magnifiques sa merci
pedn l'esu impeccable il sort du magasin
hélas une tempête l'aso qui coule mais
du lomo mais trempé trempé et tours et
récit d'un coup ou autre et s'il veut le
tout autour les gens tout revient comme
ça il va s'amuser et m'a vendu de la
merde et grands magasins
elle attrape taille mais vous avez dit
que vous étiez à mon fils comme la
grande y est
[Applaudissements]
toujours dans un troquet mais qui dit
mehdi était sacrément un gros con toi
qui regarde un autre il aimait vraiment
est vraiment un gros con tu étais même
le roi des coups en fait
mais ici devait y avoir un concours je
pense que tu tu finis à la deuxième
le rien lui dire pourquoi je suis ni un
deuxième libé parce que tu serais trop
con pour être premier en fait c'est
subtil doigt les lemmings
nous sommes aux jeux olympiques arabes
des jeux olympiques pour les handicapés
donc nos jeux paralympiques du coup
c'est la finale du 50 m nage libre
il reste trois candidats le premier n'a
pas de jambes le deuxième n'a pas de
bras et le troisième n'a ni jambes ni
bras le départ de la course est donné
le premier qui n'avaient pas de bras
arrive en premier celui qui n'a pas de
jambes arrivent en deuxième et celui qui
n'a ni bras ni jambes coule et se noie
et ils vont la trappe et ils vont
amputer les sauveteurs est en panne et
qui vont ils plongent
il leur sort bureau et tous les temps
mais je me suis aménagé pourquoi vous
êtes inscrits aux jeux olympiques et
sûrs ça fait deux ans que je m'entraîne
à nager avec mes oreilles mais je savais
pas que le bol est obligatoire